la intervención de nuestra enviada
especial la de Catalina Gómez angele
quien está en este momento acompañada de
masina Ale el shaker él es analista
político y económico invitado para
hablar también de esta conmemoración de
dos décadas de guerra y dicho esto
Catalina tiene usted la palabra
como usted decía Ángela nos encontramos
con baseker que es analista y político y
económico y quien ha estado aquí en el
país durante estos 20 años de guerra y
de inestabilidad Y empezamos contando
más en algo personal
sí quisiera hacer una pregunta personal
Cómo es la vida su vida personal como ha
cambiado desde esta invasión hace 20
años ha cambiado mucho en primer lugar
Quiero agradecer por invitarme creo que
la vida cambió increíblemente porque
pasamos de básicamente ninguna vida a
una vida real antes de 2003 solamente
había dos canales en televisión no había
satélites no había internet no había
teléfono celular entonces la gente no
tenía idea ni información del exterior
Estuve aquí desde 2003 hasta ahora
continuamente 20 años hoy la gente sabe
sabe cómo vive la gente en Sudamérica
conocen lenguajes están aprendiendo de
YouTube están aprendiendo
nuevos tipos de comida entonces sus ojos
están abiertos Esto es lo principal que
ha ocurrido si usted está hablando de lo
positivo que la gente discute en Irak de
la libertad de expresión de la
Democracia la libertad para elegir a sus
gobernantes pero de otras maneras muchas
personas han sido asesinadas muchas
guerras han ocurrido una tras otra han
ocurrido en este país quisiera que
hablemos de lo difícil que ha sido estos
20 años también para ir acá por supuesto
ha sido muy difícil
los primeros días la gente estaba de
hecho feliz porque obviamente esa dama
era un dictador brutal como Hitler como
stalin la gente no le gustaba pero lo
que pasó después de los asesinatos
masivos posiblemente un millón de
personas murió entre la guerra
entre Isis los bombardeos Y por supuesto
los países vecinos no fueron muy útiles
ni nos oyeron mucho pero en general creo
que el cambio fue positivo porque ahora
se está pensando la gente puede salir y
manifestarse lo que no se podía en el
pasado pero no significa que cuando se
manifieste obtenga lo que necesita ahora
supuestamente tenemos democracia pero lo
que realmente tenemos es una
cleptocracia significa que es el régimen
de las pandillas hay varias entre 15 y
20 pandillas cada una de ellas tiene
estaciones de televisión bancos pequeños
ejércitos
en la mayoría de personas dicen que en
las épocas de Sadam había una coco Ahora
hay mil Cocos
hay gente de la ciudad que uno no conoce
son recogidas en
gente armada que pueden matar una
familia entera Este es el problema que
muchas personas aquí realmente señalan
hay democracia pero la gente que ha
estado usando esa democracia
especialmente
partidos políticos
lo vimos en 2019 como miles de miles de
personas fueron a las calles a
manifestarse en contra de ellos pero no
tuvieron nada desafortunadamente cierto
yo estaba entre ellos estuvimos ahí
manifestándonos y hoy hay alrededor de
15 personas en Irak que son billonarios
están entre los el top 100 del mundo y
esas personas antes de 2003 ni siquiera
Tenían un carro
todas esas personas de la nada Se
tomaron el país de pronto representan
dos por ciento del país más de 30% dirá
que está bajo la línea de pobreza y el
resto son pobres pero están por encima
de la línea de pobreza el ingreso
promedio es de 500 dólares 400 dólares
15 personas 15 pandillas ellos son
dueños de 80 por ciento del país más o
menos pasamos de un gobierno muy
socialista de esa materia Un gobierno
muy capitalista y fue mucho peor que el
capitalismo como dije la cleptocracia
ellos manejan el país desafortunadamente
el mundo tiene que importar petróleo de
Irak entonces lidiar con esas personas
al interior de Irak estamos felices de
ver que se exporte petróleo pero no
vemos el dinero del petróleo ni el
petróleo solamente escuchamos de él pero
nadie se está beneficiando
estamos viendo por supuesto después de
la guerra en contra de Isis en 2017 la
excusa de gobierno había sido siempre
decir que tenemos que gastar dinero
luchando en contra de la violencia la
guerra
pero estos grupos no son tan importantes
ya
cree usted en el poder de la sociedad
civil para cambiar para lograr cambio
político en el país en el futuro si no
hay violencia sí pero hay violencia y
como usted estaba diciendo Yo fui parte
de la manifestación de 2019 800 personas
fueron asesinadas justo aquí a la vuelta
yo estaba aquí en el tope del edificio
Ellos tenían a francotiradores jóvenes
gente de 15 16 años fueron disparados en
la cabeza porque estos billonarios no
quieren perder nada Entonces no se
preocupan si no hay violencia por
supuesto creo que hay un movimiento
civil Pero cómo puede ser Cómo puede uno
acabar con esas personas ellos controlan
todo como dije tienen las milicias
tienen mafias tienen narcotráfico tienen
tráfico de licor todo lo que usted
espera que están haciendo lo están
haciendo para mantenerse en el poder la
gente tiene que manifestarse pero cada
vez que se manifiestan perdemos más
jóvenes hablamos de algo que también
bueno existe otro gran problema otro
gran problema real aquí en el poder de
estas milicias
por ejemplo se han convertido en parte
de la lucha en contra de Dash pero en un
rol muy importante pero después de estos
se hicieron un problema muy grande
algunos de ellos Se volvieron muy
grandes y poderosos
y han sido respaldados por en algunos
como de usted del poder de estas
milicias ahora el pmu usted está
hablando esto es correcto algunos son
actúan con bondad Pero estas personas
podrían trabajar bien durante el día por
el pm o por el hackento y en la noche
siguen armados y tienen todas las armas
pueden hacer otras cosas hemos escuchado
de gente que resulta violada de robos
hogares que estos porque usted está
diciendo que hacen parte de las
instituciones institucional del gobierno
eso es cierto es en parte del gobierno
reciben salarios del gobierno pero ya
que están armados
su población Posiblemente sea de 200.000
en la realidad solamente son 60.000 son
lo que llamamos
fantasmas el liderazgo del pmf recibe
los fondos el gobierno de los salarios
pero cuando el gobierno pide la lista de
nombres Ellos dicen no esto es por
seguridad resulta que solamente 60.000
son del pmf que recibe el salario el
resto son fantasmas solo para terminar
uno de los grandes problemas es que no
hay trabajos en el país ni para jóvenes
y que son la mayoría de el país como se
va a manejar ese problema en el futuro
desafortunadamente no hay ningún plan el
Gobierno no tiene un plan económico
hace unos cuantos días ellos presentaron
el presupuesto presupuesto de tres años
el mundo tiene un presupuesto anual pero
Dios quiere un presupuesto de tres años
para que no haya ningún tipo de revisión
para que puedan robar todo lo que puedan
por los próximos tres años como usted
escuchó el último Primer Ministro dijo
que 600 mil millones de dólares fueron
robados de Irak eso representa 30% del
ingreso del país
Muchas gracias por su presencia
apasionantes sobre no solamente lo que
han sido estos últimos 20 años y no de
la vida
pulga